its population may be small but Finland
is a serious military power
a military power which in the next few
days will apply to join NATO adding
extra punch to the alliance
a move clearly irking neighboring leader
Vladimir Putin who told the country's
president in a call today it would be
wrong to abandon military neutrality
as reported Mr Putin reassured finland's
president that it's not a threat but it
seems that opinion is no longer shared
on this side of the border with the
country's leader believing NATO
membership is now Paramount to the
country's security
allies like Britain have been backing
Finland joining the club but getting
into NATO needs sign off from all of the
current members and turkey isn't totally
convinced
I don't want to make any conclusions
about the latest statements we have
discussed the matter with turkey and
also other other countries and so far
all the reactions has been very positive
towards Finnish membership in NATO as
International tensions grow today Russia
cut off electricity to Finland the
suppliers say they haven't been paid
the finished grid operator assured
people there's no need to panic it
wasn't a big surprise that the
electricity was cut from Russia it was
uh that was what we anticipated and we
were prepared for that
despite continued warnings of possible
Kremlin retribution this country looks
ready to join the alliance extending
NATO's reach along Russia's border
Siobhan Robbins Sky News Finland